Traduttore: Isabelle Andrieu
Revisore: Jacopo Ghislanzoni
Di fronte a questa immagine,
non rimarrete indifferenti, lo so,
perché questa è un'immagine di guerra
e ci tira fuori tanti sentimenti.
Non è solamente la guerra che distrugge,
la guerra che crea disastri,
che crea ferite.
È una guerra che porta fuori
dei sentimenti molto, molto pesanti.
Perché ho scelto questo quadro
per parlarvi del mio tema?
Perché vorrei che vi concentraste
proprio su questi sentimenti,
che sono non solo la devastazione,
ma sono lo sgomento,
la disperazione, ma anche
l'incredulità e la paura.
Ecco, questo è quello
che provano tantissime donne
in una guerra sotterranea
che abbiamo di fianco tutti i giorni
e che io ho scoperto
praticamente quasi per caso.
Era il 1990,
mi sono avvicinata a degli avvocati
che contestavano quella che allora
era una decisione dell'America
di attaccare l'Iraq, di attaccare i paesi
che avevano il petrolio,
e eravamo avvocati per la pace.
E lì abbiamo contestato
quel modo prepotente di dominio
che si voleva imporre.
Non so se qualcuno di voi ricorda,
si parlava di una possibile
terza guerra mondiale,
la guerra del Golfo.
In quella occasione una donna
mi ha avvicinata in un'assemblea
in cui parlavamo di tutte queste cose,
mi ha detto: "Ma perché non vieni
nella nostra associazione?
Stiamo costruendo un gruppo di donne
che si occupino di donne
che subiscono violenza".
Mi ha subito incuriosita.
Sono andata, ho accettato questo invito
e ho scoperto veramente
una guerra sotterranea,
una guerra che le donne raccontavano,
ma ancora non si conosceva
e non se ne parlava come se ne parla oggi.
Ma chi erano queste donne?
Erano tanti tipi di donne.
C'era molto pregiudizio,
si pensava che fossero solo
donne disperate,
senza mezzi, senza capacità,
che non avessero studiato.
In realtà no,
mi sono ritrovata addirittura
delle mie colleghe
che mi raccontavano situazioni di violenze
che veramente sembrano sempre incredibili.
Casalinghe, manager,
libere professioniste,
persone di ceto basso,
di ceto medio, di ceto alto,
persone con capacità economiche.
Normalmente si pensa
che se uno ha capacità economiche
non arrivi a certi livelli. Non è vero.
Abbiamo subito detto
che questa violenza era trasversale.
E come mai allora continuava ad esserci?
Un aforisma mi aiuta, che dice:
"che è più facile entrare
in quasi ogni cosa che uscirne".
È proprio vero. Infatti noi ascoltavamo
tutti quei racconti e dicevamo,
"Come facciamo ad aiutare queste donne
perché possano uscire dalla violenza?".
Affiancandoci a loro e sostenendole.
Quindi abbiamo cominciato a studiare
che cosa si potesse fare
in modo anche attento, competente,
anche scientifico.
Tutto però ci è sempre venuto
dai racconti delle donne.
Il ciclo della violenza è stato studiato
alla fine degli anni '70 in America,
Leonor Walker che era una terapista,
avendo ascoltato
tante donne lo ha costruito,
lo ha proprio, diciamo, portato
perché fosse a conoscenza di tutti
come si possono sviluppare queste storie.
E che cos'è il ciclo della violenza?
Ci racconta come ci si entra
in questo tunnel
e quanto sia difficile uscirne.
C'è una prima fase che è quella
della crescita della tensione,
che è quella della provocazione,
dove ci sono tanti momenti
molto particolari che...
Tra l'altro ogni storia fa a sé.
C'è la donna che ci racconta
della pasta che non è piaciuta
per un qualsiasi pretesto,
e magari presa insieme al piatto,
buttata al cestino.
La pasta tirata sulla testa della donna.
Tutti racconti che io ho ascoltato.
E uno si domanda ma perché una donna
rimane dentro a questa situazione?
È la prima domanda
che si fa in genere alle donne.
Beh, io vi vorrei portare qui
la voce di una donna che ho seguito
e che è uscita dalla violenza
e che mi piaceva lo dicesse
perché è l'ha detto
in maniera molto chiara
proprio davanti
ad un giudice questo perché.
Perché ero innamorata di lui
e pensavo che potesse cambiare.
"Perché ero innamorata di lui
e pensavo che potesse cambiare."
È altrettanto tipico.
Uno dice, "Mah, strano.
Come mai queste donne
stanno in questa situazione?".
Eppure dobbiamo fare i conti
anche con il sentimento.
E l'altra cosa?
Si passa da una fase
quindi dove cresce la tensione,
si fanno delle provocazioni
piccole o grandi,
alla fase dove scoppia la tensione.
Scoppia con un'aggressione,
ma attenzione che non è
solo un'attenzione fisica.
Può essere anche un'aggressione verbale,
può essere anche un impaurire
attraverso la rotture di oggetti,
attraverso lo sbattimento delle porte,
attraverso tutta una serie di atti
che portano a dire,
"Qui decido io quello che si fa
e come lo si fa".
E allora questa è la fase in cui,
dallo smarrimento iniziale,
si arriva proprio allo sgomento,
perché è una persona che ti vuole bene
che ti sta facendo quella cosa,
è una persona a cui tu magari
hai affidato tante confidenze,
un pezzo della tua vita.
E quindi, se è sgomento, come reagisce?
Vi voglio portare
ancora la voce di questa donna.
Ho sempre nutrito la speranza
che fosse anche colpa mia,
e che comportandomi diversamente
tutto questo non sarebbe successo.
Ecco, lei dice:
"Ho nutrito la speranza
che fosse anche colpa mia".
Addirittura.
Questa è una frase che fa rabbrividire.
Io quando l'ho sentita e l'ho letta
nel processo penale
pensavo di avere sbagliato
anche a leggerla.
In realtà è proprio così.
Lei spera che sia così
per darsi la possibilità di uscirne.
Il problema è che non se ne esce,
perché cosa succede?
C'è la fase della cosiddetta
"Luna di miele",
che è quella forse
alla fine anche più pericolosa,
anche più pericolosa dell'aggressione,
perché fa pensare ad una donna
che il pentimento
e le attenzioni amorevoli
che in quel momento il violento porta
per riuscire a recuperare una situazione
che forse sta perdendo di mano,
eh, forse lo faranno cambiare,
forse succederà qualcosa
per cui non ci sarà più,
quella situazione lì non si ripeterà.
Invece Leonor Walker ci dice proprio
che questo è un ciclo che va a ripetersi,
è un tunnel
e noi quando intercettiamo le donne
vorremmo che in quella fase,
tra il secondo momento del maltrattamento
e quello della luna di miele decidessero,
perché quello è il momento giusto
per poterne uscire,
è il momento in cui
lo sgomento si trasforma in paura,
qui tornano i sentimenti di una guerra,
e si può cambiare qualcosa.
E invece il ciclo ricomincia
se da lì non se ne esce
e si crede a quel pentimento.
Vorrei farvi sentire per l'ultima volta
la voce di questa donna.
Quello che non capivo è come lui
dopo le liti mostruose
in cui mi insultava nei modi peggiori,
"Vaffanculo, stronza",
parolacce di ogni tipo,
quando si calmava voleva avere
un rapporto sessuale con me,
e io non potevo dire di no,
altrimenti sarebbe
ricominciato tutto da capo.
Ecco, lei aveva già messo in conto
di non potere dire di no,
perché altrimenti
ricominciava tutto da capo.
La paura, la paura che paralizza
una donna che sta dentro questa situazione
è quella che consente al violento
di procedere e di andare avanti.
In tutte queste fasi,
quando si arriva al maltrattamento,
quando si riprende il ciclo,
il maltrattamento che arriva
la volta successiva,
lo dico sempre, a tutte
le donne che incontro,
è un maltrattamento
che è sempre più grave,
e quindi è importantissimo
poter fare il passo di uscita
il prima possibile.
E quali sono i numeri della violenza
di genere in Italia?
Forse li avrete anche già sentiti.
Una donna su tre, tra i 16 e i 70 anni,
ha subito violenza,
e alla fine l'ISTAT ha calcolato
che sono 7 milioni queste donne,
di cui 4,5 milioni
hanno subito violenza sessuale
e un milione e più ha subito
violenza sessuale ancora più grave,
cioè stupri o tentati stupri.
Questa è la situazione dei numeri.
Sono numeri che non cambiano,
sono numeri che si ripetono,
sono numeri che abbiamo fatto emergere
anche con il lavoro
dei centri antiviolenza.
Ma con il nostro lavoro
abbiamo messo in evidenza anche i costi.
Perché noi dobbiamo, anche,
porci questa domanda:
che cosa succede quando
una donna subisce violenza?
Succedono tantissime cose
comunque anche all'esterno,
e quindi andare ad un pronto soccorso,
richiederà un terapeuta,
prenderà dei farmaci,
chiamerà la polizia,
forse farà una denuncia,
la denuncia sembra che sia
quella che risolva tutto.
Non è detto che questo sia,
anzi molto spesso non lo è, purtroppo.
Ci sono tribunali
che lavorano costantemente su questi temi.
Ci sono tutte le spese legali,
le spese dei servizi sociali
e le spese, anche,
dei centri antiviolenza
che fanno la loro parte.
E tutti questi costi, moltiplicati
per il fattore produttività,
perché una donna che subisce violenza
non sarà a livello sociale
la stessa persona,
non potrà essere attiva come lo è
chi vive serenamente,
più o meno, la propria vita.
Che risultato dà questa operazione?
È stata stimata in 26 miliardi di Euro.
E noi riteniamo
che sia anche sottostimata,
sto parlando dell'Italia,
non sto parlando del mondo, ovviamente.
E nel 2017 in Italia,
circa 50.000 donne si sono rivolte
ad un centro antiviolenza.
Capite che qui i numeri non tornano.
I numeri sono tutti da rivedere
e tra poco vi dirò anche come,
per coinvolgere tutti noi
in quello che possiamo fare,
anche se non lavoriamo
in un centro antiviolenza.
Perché questo?
Perché noi vi vorremmo anche,
soprattutto le donne,
vedere nel nostro centro, anche aiutarci.
In tanti modi si può aiutare
un centro antiviolenza,
ma qui oggi non voglio chiedervi
questo tipo di aiuto.
Né un aiuto personale,
né un aiuto economico,
dal punto di vista dello starci
e del sostenere,
perché in genere sulla violenza
si fa sempre questo passaggio.
Quello che vi vorrei chiedere
invece è quello di aiutarci tutti
a ridurre questo numero di donne
che devono rivolgersi
ai centri antiviolenza.
Come, direte voi?
Eh, qui la situazione
la dobbiamo valutare tutti insieme,
perché oggi si parla di cambiamenti
e noi dobbiamo pensare
che purtroppo su questo tema
di cambiamento
non ce n'è stato moltissimo,
perché anche la manager,
anche la persona che ha disponibilità
economiche, culturali, capacità
rientra dentro questa situazione,
perché è una questione
di relazioni intime.
Si dice che la violenza sia un rapporto,
sia determinata da un rapporto
di dominio tra generi.
Se questo è vero allora vediamo un attimo,
perché c'è la prevenzione
che è importante, per noi.
In che cosa può consistere la prevenzione?
La prevenzione la possiamo fare tutti,
incominciando dall'educazione,
dall'educazione dei nostri figli.
Io dico sempre, ci sono stereotipi
che noi non riusciamo ancora a scalfire.
Al maschietto si dice,
"Non piangere come una femminuccia",
il maschietto lo si iscrive a calcio,
lo si iscrive a rugby,
gli si fanno fare sport, diciamo,
di una certa forza, virulenza;
alla femmina si dice,
"Non fare il maschiaccio,
comportati bene, sii educata, sii carina",
soprattutto "Sii carina".
Quando noi facciamo tutto questo...
Tante femmine, tantissime
ragazzine vanno a danza,
la danza ormai è
tutto il mondo delle ragazzine.
Allora quando noi facciamo
questi passaggi,
rischiamo di avere costruito
una struttura che porta
quell'uomo o quella donna,
quel futuro uomo, quella futura donna
a potere entrare dentro questo meccanismo,
perché è un meccanismo
dove qualcuno domina
e qualcun altro rimane sotto.
Allora, badate,
sicuramente qui in questa sala
ci saranno persone
che o hanno subito violenza
o hanno agito in violenza.
E, se i numeri e la statistica
ce la raccontano giusta,
come io credo,
dovremmo cominciare a farci delle domande
su come noi ci comportiamo,
e questa è la prima cosa
scomoda che io vi dico,
perché se noi continueremo
a comportarci in questo modo,
saremo anche conviventi
con certe forme di violenza.
Se noi giriamo la testa, ad esempio,
rispetto all'amica, rispetto alla collega,
rispetto al collega che si può comportare
in maniera non scorretta, di più,
che si può portare in maniera aggressiva,
perché tanto ad una donna
si possono dire tante cose,
non reagirà nello stesso modo
in cui potrebbe reagire un uomo.
Ecco, allora mettiamo le basi per questo.
Quindi quello che vi chiedo è di cambiare,
di cambiare il nostro modo di pensare,
sapendo che le donne stanno dentro
quel ciclo della violenza
perché noi a volte giriamo
anche la faccia dall'altra parte
o perché noi abbiamo costruito
quel modo di stare delle donne
dentro alle situazione
e i rapporti di coppia.
Quindi cambiare le nostre menti
per cambiare le nostre azioni
e forse per essere
un po' più liberi e felici tutti.
Grazie.
(Applausi)